This concludes our Administrative and Regulatory Affairs Budget
workshop. We will now begin our budget workshop for the municipal
courts. And at this time, I would like to welcome Judge
Elaine Marshall and CFO Nellie Santos to
provide the municipal courts budget presentation.
Put the chair up too high. Thank. Thank you.
Welcome, your Honor. And that floor is yours.
And good afternoon and
council members. I am here and it is my pleasure to present today the
Municipal Court Department's FY 23 Budget.
Attending with me today is McD's Chief Financial Officer,
Deputy Director Nellie Santos, and she's seated with me today
as well as members of my executive team who are in the audience.
This presentation is reflective of our commitment to
our community to provide court services in an equitable
and safe manner. Next slide, please.
Our General Fund consists of seven cost centers,
each of them having budgets assigned, staffed, and specific core
services. This slide includes four of the seven
cost centers. The system support cost. Center has no assigned
FTEs. Next slide.
This slide includes the remaining three General Fund cost
centers. Next slide.
Municipal Court also manages four special funds that provide specific
services, including security, technology, and truancy
prevention. The Municipal Jury Fund is our fourth special
fund and currently has no assigned FTEs or
expenditure budget. This is a newly created fund and
expenditures will be budgeted once the fund balance increases.
Next slide, please.
Listed on this slide are McD's major services.
These services help us to achieve our overall goals and
our mission. Next slide.
Our courts are mandated by law to provide a legal forum for
the individuals charged with criminal offenses. Included in
these mandates are the right to a jury trial, equal access to
the legal system, and adherence to our state and local law.
Next slide, please.
Sorry. Oh. Next slide,
please. MCD has
many internal revenue generating initiatives that provide enhanced
court services to the public and assist municipal courts
in achieving its overall revenue target. These services include
passports, weddings notary, and the printing of driving
records to better serve target areas within our community.
We have various specialized dockets that provide meaningful
and safe methods for case resolution,
including the Veterans Court and the Safe Harbor Court.
Judges assigned to these dockets have the ability to reduce fines,
offer payment plans, or other methods of case resolution
to individuals who are experiencing hardships but who
still want to fulfill their legal obligations to the court.
I'm happy to report that Teen Court was able to resume their
in person monthly activities in FY 22. This program
has made long lasting impressions on the lives of our youth by providing
a glimpse at the legal system through firsthand participation
and through mentorship provided by our professional volunteers.
Next slide, please. I think
we're one slide ahead of me now. There we
go. MCD began decentralizing court services
many years ago, anticipating the future growth in
the population. We serve our full service courts can
be found in key areas of the city and they include our central
location, Macawa, West Side and North
Command. We also have annex courts that are open
and located in Kingwood and the Clear Lake areas which are open
one day per week, and a court at the Joint Processing
Center which we perform and they handle jail, dockets and magistrate
court services, and we do those. That court is in
operation seven days a week, 22 hours a day,
365 days a year. We also anticipated
the greater use of technology and have implemented many web
based processes. Our short term messaging service
provides text messages and email reminders to our
customers about upcoming scheduled court dates, as well
as important emergency notifications to address
the needs of our diverse community and to allow full participation in the
legal service. We have full time certified Spanish
interpreters as well as access to other languages through contract
services and the language line. Next slide, please.
This slide represents a comparison of revenue for FY
21, FY 22 and FY 23 for
all MCD funds and the percentage change
between the FY 23 proposed and the FY 22
estimates. As reflected, there is an overall 3% decrease
in revenue across all funds for FY 23.
Next slide, please. Despite the COVID challenges
and the lower rate of citation issuance, we expect FY
22 General Fund revenues to exceed the
budget target. This increase is attributed to the resumption of
all the dockets, including cases that were delayed during the suspension
period. This increase is also due to the high level of
performance from our internal and external collection teams,
McD's revenue generated initiatives, and the deferred
payment program for FY 23.
We project a slight decrease in General Fund revenue from the
FY 22 projection due to a reduction in the
number of backlog cases and a continued lower citation
rates. Next slide, please. This slide
includes revenue highlights for our four MCD
special funds. The annual variances in
the revenue budgets for the funds remain in line with the General
Fund for FY 23. We anticipate a
reduction in the grant funding from the office of the Governor for our
Juvenile Case Manager Truancy Prevention initiative.
Through this grant, we have been able to expand our program to additional
schools. However, this reduction may negatively impact the
services we provide to our partner school districts. Next slide,
please. This slide represents a
comparison of expenditures for FY 21,
FY 22 and FY 23 for all
MCD funds and the percentage change between FY
23 proposed and FY 22 budgets.
There is a 2.3 overall increase in expenditures across
all MCD funds for FY 23.
Next slide, please.
80% of the General Fund expenditure budget consists of
personnel cost. The remaining 20% is non
personnel costs that include inner fund accounts, CSMART,
support supplies and services. Next slide,
please.
99% of the building security fund expenditure
budget is non personnel and it includes contract
security services. The remaining 1% of the budget
is personnel and is related to the retiree health benefits
cost. Next slide, please.
The majority of the court technology fund expenditure budget
is nonpersonal. It includes software and
hardware licensing, maintenance costs,
CSMART support and other planned technology enhancements.
The remaining 18% is personnel cost.
Next slide, please. 90% of
the local Tourancy Prevention and Diversion Fund
expenditure budget is personnel costs. The remaining
10% is non personnel cost, including education
and training supplies, as well as teen court and
student engagement activities. Next slide.
This worksheet provides an overview of the expenditure net
change between the FY 22 and the FY
23 General Fund budgets. FY 23
reflects a 2.2% increase in expenditures.
This increase is due to the resumption of dockets and the related
increases in court services, noticing jury cost,
postage language services, variances in the inner
fund accounts, pension and health benefit rates, and the two Hope
3% increases. Next slide, please.
This slide provides our FY 23 expenditure highlights
for the General Fund. We will continue to maintain
the court CSMART System fund, contractual increases
in the security and armored car service, language services,
passport program costs, and citation book printing.
Next slide, please. This slide provides
expenditure highlights for our four special revenue funds.
Expenditures in these funds include contract security services,
technology maintenance and enhancement cost, and Truancy
prevention services. Two of these four funds include
personnel cost. Next slide.
This concludes the budget portion. Now we'll proceed to the next section of
this presentation. The next section of the presentation will highlight
other department level information. Next slide, please.
This list provides more detail regarding our citywide
interfund our citywide restricted accounts. Sorry.
Next slide, please. The MCD
organizational chart on this slide includes our leadership team and
lines of direct and indirect reporting. Next slide.
The information provided here reflects the diversity of our municipal court
team. Next slide, please.
I am pleased to be able to share with you some of our major accomplishments
from this past year on the next two slides. While we remained
operational throughout COVID Pandemic, we suspended
regular dockets and jury service for over a year.
This resulted in a large number of our cases that needed to be
reset and rescheduled. We have worked diligently
since then, resuming dockets from last April to reschedule these
cases, handle the volume of new cases, and maintain lower
docket levels to meet safe distancing requirements. We also
summoned jurors at a reduced level and found a solution
for masking by implementing a clear mask option for
the jurors selected for trials. Our Passport program
is celebrating its first year anniversary.
To date, our Passport program has assisted almost 3000
individuals to obtain their passports and has generated
$115,000 in that year.
I'm extremely proud of our staff who has worked very hard to obtain their certification
as passport agents and their dedication to the
success of our program. Our program has been recognized by
the US. Department of State for excellent customer service and
for increasing the availability of this public service.
Next slide. In order to better serve
our other areas of our community, the Juvenile Case Manager Program
expanded its Truancy prevention services to include
the Aldine Independent School District this past year.
Our Deferred Payment Program was recently recognized
by the Government Collections Association of Texas as being the
most innovative collection program for 2021.
This program has a great team of dedicated staff who work very
closely with individuals who need time to pay their fines and who
track cases through the successful compliance.
Court security remains at the forefront in our today's challenging
environment. McD's Court Security Committee
includes broad range of internal and external participants,
and we meet monthly to discuss security related
issues. Next slide, please. The major unmet
need for MCD is the
replacement of our central facility. We suffered
major damage from Hurricane Harvey almost five years ago.
Our court staff has been extremely flexible and
several workarounds have been implemented, including doubling
up in courts, doubling up in offices, sharing workspaces,
and dealing with additional flooding and infrastructure
failures as they arise and occur throughout the building.
We are currently working very closely with the Mayor, GSD,
Finance and FEMA to find a permanent solution for
this ongoing facility replacement project. Next slide,
please. This concludes the presentation of our
FY 23 budget. Just wanted to thank my entire court
team. They have been resilient and positive throughout this
entire five years, doing the things that were necessary to keep the courts
up, to keep the courts running, to keep the courts operational,
and they have been doing an excellent job. And I would also
like to thank the mayor, all of you council members for your continued
support and my partner departments as GSD.
Sometimes they let me knock out a wall, sometimes they won't.
But we have done everything we can to keep the courts at the central location
up and running for our citizens of Houston. And at this time, I welcome
any questions you have. Thank you. Judge, do you have any insight
on our site and release initiative? How many cases come
to courts based on the site and release program?
Site and release? Yes.
They never come to municipal court for Class C misdemeanors?
No, sir. Okay.
All right. What about the associate judges positions?
Have we filled those or how are we looking for the Associate
municipal court judges? We are still going through the
boards of commission to see who is applying. To date, we really don't
have very many applicants because we are looking for more applicants
for the Associate Judge position. I think I
have contacted Jackie and the
newest person there who took Maria's place, and we're
still trying to get applicants in. If you could send
additional information to my office again like you all did earlier
in the year so we can reach out to our networks to see if
we can get some people to apply, we'll do great council
Member Abby Cayman. Thank you, Vice Chair.
Judge, I think you've spotlighted all of the
challenges that the municipal courts continue to face, again,
distinct from criminal and civil.
But going back to the accomplishments you listed, I know when
we've been talking at Public Safety Committee night court,
team court,
all of the different efforts to meet people where
they are, make sure they aren't unduly penalized and
do right by them and do right by the city and law enforcement.
Right. So I just want to give you all credit for that really
quickly on the building, because you mentioned that.
Talk to us about some of those challenges, if you can. Again,
we are still dealing with the impacts of Harvey
COVID, the structural damage. But what is that doing
to the court process? The ability to function day to
day. When Harvey hit, it wiped out the
entire basement, as everybody knows. And we had six
courts, I think, in operation. We had a bonding section,
parking section, the bailiffs, we had different offices there.
So all of those offices had to move
somewhere. And the only court we had on the first floor
was one court. And we have all of the cashiers and
their departments there. The second floor had courtrooms.
And so we have staff that we have
renovated closets to put supervisors in.
We have judges that are doubling up with courts and court dockets.
We have done everything we could to maintain the
atmosphere of a court that's friendly and safe for everyone.
And then came COVID. And with COVID you can't
stand close to each other. So it took the limited amount
of space we had in the courtroom and cut it in half.
And so that's how we have been operating now,
but we're opening back up into sitting next to each other.
But I have been mandated by the Supreme Court
and I've given the authority to have everyone wear a mask
because we see 2000, 3000 people a day. I just
think it's safer that way for the employees. And I appreciate that
because more shutdowns are going to create a further backlog. So I
completely get that really quickly.
In terms of other needs, concerns for the future,
talk to me about truancy prevention and how that's going. Our truancy
prevention is basically we have
a fund from we have grant funding and we started out
with grant funding that was around the $700,000
range. We have seven juvenile case managers that operate
under that grant. We have now submitted
a request for additional grants and right now
it's pending approval temporarily.
They're saying that we may get 100,000. If we just get 100,000.
There may be some other options we have to have to go to do so.
That is an unmet need because for the school district to
have juvenile case managers in there who know the
kids if they come to teen court, the defendants who come to
teen court, chances are a juvenile case manager
knows that kid. And if we have to cut it,
it's going to be a disservice, I think, to our youth.
I just received word on the way yesterday to
Teen Court's final thing that I do believe.
I don't know if he is my first, but one of the first
juveniles student volunteers that came through Teen
Court is about to graduate from the University of Houston's Law
School. So I was very proud of that.
But if the Juvenile case managers,
if we have enough money to keep what
we have, we can work. But I'm not really sure we're going to be able
to keep what we have with just that amount of grant funding.
So are you saying that we may lose the 700,000 that
we currently have? 700,000 is what they started
off giving us. Then we went down to 500 and
now the proposed is 125,
I think you're saying is the Truancy program as is cannot continue.
We have seven JCMS that are funded there. We may be able
to fund three, but four we may lose.
If you could keep us apprised of that,
I would very much appreciate that.
Council Member David Robinson. Thank you, Chair judge
Marshall, thank you for being here. In your final page
of your final slide of your appendix
and your final bullet on that final page,
you asked a mouthful, stating, in partnership
with the Mayor's office, Finance, GSD and FEMA, we continue to
seek an agreeable option for the replacement of the Central Court facility.
Do you have anything to add to that,
please, council members?
Can we get your support as well? You have my support.
I think our hands are basically tied by FEMA right
now. For them to say, yes,
we'll give you this funding, or no, we won't give you this funding,
or yes, we're giving you some. And it has been
like so there are some plans out there,
Judge, as you know. And I guess what I'm asking you is
if you have anything more to add and it sounds like we're in a pattern.
Okay, thank you very much.
Thank you, Judge, and Miss Santos for your presentations.
And you are dismissed. Thank you. Thank you.
And also thank you to your entire staff, your whole team back there,
everyone who's in the chambers and not here. Thank you all for everything you do
as well.
We will now move into the public comment period.
I will start with the virtual speakers. Please press star six to unmute
when you hear your name. The first speaker is Ms.
Saba Blanding.
Hey, good afternoon again. I had
a couple of questions. The first is, is there a plan
to extend and expand the Safe Harbor Court from
a public safety presentation? Last year, we had processed around
1000 with 500,000 cases outstanding.
How many people have been served in comparison to the eligible population?
And then my second question is in regards
to the truancy prevention initiatives. I'm curious what
organizations and departments are collaborating in truancy prevention
initiatives. Are there others in the Houston ecosystem
to engage for compassionate approaches to truancy prevention?
So for great questions, the first one, we're going to take
that question and get a response from you regarding
the Safe Harbor courts. So please submit
that in writing over to District E at district
E at Houst Gov and we'll get back to you shortly.
Your second question on the truancy. I know
that my Brother's Keeper, as well as the Credible Messenger program
that we initiated last year, are working in collaboration with
the municipal courts on the truancy issues.
They do collaborations with the wraparound service and college counselors
at some of the high schools. So they
are working in tandem with different stakeholders
and community groups on enhancing that program and trying
to make sure that it's beneficial for the youth.
Okay. Thank you. You're welcome.
Amanda she.
Hi, thank you. It feels like a theme
across a lot of these budget presentations,
like from the Health Department, department of Neighborhoods, things like that,
is we're losing a lot of budget
in terms of support for the youth.
And I think this is just a statement, really. It just
feels like a really great loss in a time when
there's already so much for the kids to overcome
what was having lost a lot of support with
the schools and things like that. Yeah, I just
wanted to highlight that. Thank you for highlighting that. And also
be mindful that outside of just the city of Houston,
there are many nonprofits
and different organizations with youth emphasis that we
collaborate with all of our offices, kind of work with some of these neighborhood
and after school program groups that are focused on youth
engagement. And so although some of the funding may not be
there through the city of Houston, there are still ways in which we partner
with a lot of great agencies that are still doing similar wonderful
work for the youth as well. The next
speaker is Jason Oliver.
I want to pick up where Amanda left off. I have
worked closely with my brother's Keeper on initiatives, and it
looks like we're set to lose it from the Health Department.
And I remember looking at all those that were
green, right, that were funded from the general fund,
which was a small portion in comparison to the
red that were not funded. So, yes, there are
a lot of programs in the community and right and like private programs
and such, but one of the important things that somebody has brought up
before during these workshops is like the consistency when
you have a city entity or a city agency
that's putting these things forward. So I just really think it's
important to be especially as we're talking about focusing
on crime and a lot of this deals with youth and touches
youth and it's hard to find programs and
consistent programming for youth in many
spaces and areas around the city that's in no way equitably
distributed. So I just want to flag that and then
I'm trying to figure out what's going on with Site and release.
She said that it doesn't touch the municipal courts.
I'm not a lawyer, so I don't understand why
that is, but I was hoping that there would be some changes that have
been made as a result of
Site and Release adoption that we can see here in the municipal courts.
Great questions. I too am involved
with my Brother's Keeper program. I can tell you that that as
you know, was started through the Obama administration.
So many of the funds that came through for that initiative,
not only for the City of Houston, but all around the country, were federal dollars
that we find matching grants and then can also
provide dollars through our Council District service funds for specific
initiatives in our district. So that's always been a
program that we relied on for outside dollars.
When it comes to the neighborhood programs
and nonprofits regarding the youth, many times
through my experience, they actually do
a much better job of being
consistent with the youth that they see.
They're right there in those neighborhoods, in those schools, so they understand the dynamics
of each of those communities. And many times for the city,
we rely on partnering with them because they
have more of a boots on the ground and wider perspective on what are
the specific needs for those kids and those programs.
And so although the City of Houston may not put
forth some of those programs, we definitely try to support in as
many ways as possible many of our offices
allocate dollars towards the Case for Kids program with Harris County,
which does tremendous work for after school programming
and extracurricular activities for the youth. So we'll
continue to do that. But if there are specific programs
that you have highlighted or identified in the presentations that you think we
need to allocate more resources towards,
then of course, please let us know that as well and
then we'll get an answer to you on the site and release, because I have
similar questions. I was to the impression that since it was a
citable offense that it would be at the municipal court level,
but I may be wrong on that. So we're going to
get some clarification and then we'll provide that feedback as well.
So to ensure we get it to you in a prompt fashion,
if you would email that directly to District E at houst gov
and we'll get a response and
that will complete our public Speakers for the
Municipal Courts budget presentation.
Before we adjourn, please note that budget workshops
have concluded for all City of Houston departments.
We will have our next BFA Committee meeting on Tuesday,
May 31 at 10:00 a.m.. I want to give a shout out to all
the community members who took time to come in person and
speak virtually on these topics.
Your engagement was beneficial. It was of value to
us. We learned from you, and we will get any answers that have
been unanswered to you. Shortly. A reminder to all council
members to be checking SharePoint for uploaded presentations,
as well as responses for any questions submitted.
Thank you again to everyone for being here today, and this meeting is adjourned.